the face shield famously worn by andy
reid in the 2020 season who can forget
the opener when it fogged up he needed
like a windshield wiper on the inside
intermittent cycle not the whole time
just once every few seconds that is now
on display at the pro football hall of
fame a very rare artifact that
presumably will return to the possession
at some point of andy reid so that
inspired thanks to pete dimelitis who's
very creative when it comes to these
things better him than me
a draft idea
the nfl artifact specific item yeah that
we would want
to own this can go in a lot of different
directions and i have not the first pick
really matters today because it's not
like there's some obvious one out there
not that i can think of still we have to
do the trivia question chris who is the
only pro football hall of famer to wear
jersey number zero
zero
oh man
i don't think i do know this one hold on
go ahead i don't know this
gym auto raider center oh jim auto i
wouldn't i wouldn't have been able to
think of that i would not that did not
register in my brain so i'm off on that
one go ahead you get the first pick not
a historian today
the the last the last guy that i
remember wearing double zero in the nfl
was ken burrow
of the then houston oilers if you that
was before your time but i had a jersey
it wasn't a borough jersey but it was a
it was a football jersey like those
generic ones you could buy at sears yeah
and it was double zero and i love i was
proud of it so it was like casual day at
school once because we had to wear
uniform it was a catholic school so i
wore my my double zero jersey and i was
very proud of it and somebody said to me
oh is that your iq and the double zero
jersey was never worn again
yeah that was the end
the the double zero jersey pete is long
long gone all right first item that i
would like to have
in my personal collection i i gotta
start with the first thing i thought of
last night now
let me let me go full transparency
there's one thing that i thought of last
night that i forget now oh and there's
another one that i thought of last night
that i was afraid i would forget but i
remember so i'm gonna go with the one
that i remember obviously the fresca
bottle
next to len dawson in that iconic photo
of him smoking at halftime of the first
super bowl somewhere in a landfill in
southern california resides that fresco
bottle i want that fresca bottle
that would be the ultimate thing to have
there it is old school fresca bottle on
the floor folding chair
cigarette len dawson i want that fresco
oh my gosh look at that and then i mean
i mean i think i'd rather have the
cigarette butt i mean just because
let's let's get that that's amazing i
mean it really is to think that they
were smoking cigarettes and it's so
funny too because like
there was a sense that smoking
cigarettes would open up your lungs at
that time and it became like a thing
like that was crazy but that's a good
one very creative by you very creative
ultimate i mean that picture itself if
you could get that signed by len dawson
would be something i'd put in my house
so good one to start off there the first
thing that popped in my head
tom landry's hat i want tom landry's hat
in my showcase i mean i don't know is
there really a piece of clothing that
signifies
anybody more in the history of the nfl
than that hat i mean i you know again i
grew up in you know the 80s and and big
phil was playing the dallas cowboys and
of course his his silhouette is just
stained in my brain forever let alone
being you know one of the greatest
coaches of all time he came from the new
york giants and all that so that would
be the first thing that that i would
take
my dad was of the generation that wore
fedoras we had a couple of fedoras in
the house with the big hat box love it
came in the hat box was so cool was this
giant box you open it up and there's the
hat that smelled like dad not in a bad
way it just it just you know what i mean
you wear it all the time
it starts to smell like dad right um
tom landry talked about wearing a cowboy
hat when he became the coach of the
cowboys his wife who passed away not
that long ago said wear a fedora and
that was it she also apparently had a
roll in the star on the side of the
helmet so huge wow i know that mrs
landry next one for me
and this is another old school one but
this is an item that has always
fascinated me for a variety of reasons
but bob greasy
playing football
with glasses on not the john jefferson
right no action like real
actual glasses
i want a pair of those glasses and say
yeah there's a guy that actually played
football
wearing glasses like it like you'd wear
you know to read the newspaper in the
morning while you're drinking your
coffee yeah that i mean that's that that
shot right there that's hilarious first
off that really is i mean how does how
do you not hit him in the face when he's
wearing glasses like that i mean
especially in that day and age they were
like
that was like commonplace uh elbow into
your face or something like that but
that was the old line that was one of
the first lines that i learned one of
the first rules of etiquette i learned
from watching cartoons you wouldn't hit
a hit a guy who wears glasses so maybe
maybe football players stopped short
maybe that was his protection wearing
the glasses because that was the rule
you didn't hit a guy who wore glasses i
i like i i feel like i i mean a lot of
mine are old too i i don't know again
it's like i
i'd love to have brady's super bowl 51
mvp trophy like something like that like
i'd love that it's not my choice but i'm
going back to the the old days too here
again
i would love
to have
johnny united's helmet
from the 1958 nfl championship game that
would i mean that that is very specific
but you know that's the game that put
the nfl on the map right i mean the
iconic picture you know the the colts
running back running through the middle
there at yankee stadium and johnny using
the background you know alan amichi yes
thank you pete for saving me there but
johnny united of course was
the original peyton manning tom brady
whatever you want to say he was that guy
uh to me that that will always be etched
in my brain when i think of the history
of football
i keep thinking of more that i would
want like i would want the the jim
mcmahon headband that had roselle
on it i had a headband fine from jim
mcmahon from jim mcmahon it didn't say
roseville
was that when you were out in the hall
throwing the tennis ball at the at the
wall outside of his room and the pro
ball is that when you got it yeah you're
right i'm at the pro bowl and i'm bored
i'm six and a half i don't know what the
hell i'm doing you know and he i'm
sitting out in the hallway my parents
probably like get out of the room go do
something so i'm in the hallway who
knows what they were doing in the room
but either way i'm throwing the ball
against the wall
and all of a sudden jim mcmahon comes
out and he's like
what the hell is going on out here and
you know of course i look just like my
dad and i think he put two and two
together pretty quickly uh but he came
out and gave me one of the headbands and
that was like i mean couldn't be cooler
what's making you laughter
christopher chris christopher
christopher go play in the hallway i
just need 15 minutes
[Laughter]
dirty diana big phil getting after it
this is one you'll like you'll like this
one because i remember noticing this
from the moment that i got the issue of
sports illustrated early
1991 everson wall's on the cover super
bowl 25 victory with the yellow
wristband that was in honor of the
troops because the the
the first iraq war had started there it
is the yellow wristband i want that
yellow wristband yeah
man that is a i mean you're great you
got really creative that that was you
know of course i was there that was very
special but are you still laughing at me
[Laughter]
all right you got one more pick all
right um
i'm i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with the
fur coat i mean i just i gotta go with
the fur coat of joe namath it's just
another one that's come on
wait the one he wore when he when he
upstaged your dad it's people either one
i'll take either one oh there it is
there it is look at that guy
that's amazing it's absolutely amazing
look at look at big phil trying it on i
mean first off it's broadway joe he's
one of the first like real commercial
superstars in the history of the nfl
that story right there is hilarious
because he he he sandbagged my dad
really he wanted to make sure my dad was
going to dress real you know
conservative and normal are you just
gonna wear a you know a blazer yeah
blazer blaze okay phil all right i'll
wear a blazer too and he showed up in
that and then if you remember this too
remember when he flipped the coin before
the game before they told him to flip it
he just flipped it in the air when he
was ready and they had to tell him to
stop and he had to do it over uh joe
willy one of the greatest personalities
in the history of the nfl
can we cycle back through the photos
because there's there's one specific one
i think it's the next one was this the
look on your dad's face right there when
he asked you to go out in the hallway
all right i'm going to hear about this
from my parents
good good uh aunt wendy's probably
already texting you the the other i had
i had a couple others i i want the water
bottle that randy moss used when he
sprayed the official oh my god play-off
loss to the greatest show-offs on turf
in 1999 i want that water bottle oh
that's a really good one there it is oh
my gosh like well done that's amazing
randy moss is amazing how about the um i
would love to have the vince lombardi
trench coat right that you see him on
and like that he would wear that to me
wow that's another thing that's to me
goes almost like with the the fedora of
tom landry and the earl campbell tear
away jersey that was another one that i
would go
that was amazing i mean just one of the
greatest players of all time one of the
five six best running backs in the
history of the sport that i feel like
never really gets mentioned in those
you know conversations but pretty cool
that's amazing
the last one i would want
the jeff hoss detler shoes into which a
ten-year-old christopher david sims
sprayed shape
special that's very awesome with the can
of barbasol right next to it so you can
explain it what's the best thing you
currently have i'm sure you've got
something good what's the best thing you
have yeah um man i you know i do have a
brady autographed helmet that's very
special to me i got a troy aikman
uh autographed helmet
uh you know i got some cool things that
were really signed to my dad like he has
like some autographs that joe joe
montana wrote like a personal note on
there they're really funny i can't i'm
not going to say them live here on tv
but those are some of the cool things
that we got around our house
i got two things down in the barn that
are very very special to me one is my
dad's old croupier stick he used to deal
dice back in the day and that croupier
stick has got to be a hundred years old
and it is awesome it's mounted on the
wall and the other thing that i have
and i can't say who it is but there was
a time
when an nfl head coach in advance of a
big game a sunday night football game at
some point over the past decade had a
play
that he was going to use
and he wrote it up he said i'm going to
use this and it's going to work and he
mailed it to me and he used it and it
worked and it scored a touchdown i know
i know you've told me the story but yeah
i've got it i've got it in a and a case
down there i'm always afraid it's going
to walk away it's amazing i was afraid
it's going to disappear i need to lock
it up or something and he stole it from
another team if i don't if i remember
correct and then he's i'm doing it this
weekend called a shot it's gonna work
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports